[Music]
hey my name is jasmine i'm with get
caked and today we're going to show you
guys how to make some pancake art so the
thing that actually got me into pancake
art was i had seen a japanese artist
creating pancake art and following that
i had read a study that showed that the
way that our brains learn and develop
new skills
we could learn any skill that's out
there so long that we practice and
really put our mind towards it filling
the bottles is the messiest part i've
spilled bottles on the floor before
colors
we use gel food coloring because it
makes the colors pop to be very honest i
was not a fan of pancakes when i started
this with no art experience whatsoever i
decided to teach myself how to make
pancake art and ever since then i have
been making pancakes and eating them
every day and every night come on shake
shake shake
lately i've been craving pizza so i
think i'm gonna make a pizza pancake one
of the difficult things that we had went
through when it came to trial and error
was trying to make sure the temperature
of the griddle was correct and that it
wouldn't actually burn the pancakes as
we're cooking them we kept it on a low
heat just to make sure that everything
cooks evenly and it looks great on the
flip but at the same time it's just more
timing everything took me honestly like
a year to master it before i was just
really comfortable with like the process
itself are you guys ready for the flip
pizza pancakes pizza fix so it's pride
month and we are gonna make a rainbow
pancake just like every person is unique
every single pancake that we make is
unique as well really the process of
coming out it was freeing being able to
be who you are at all times is very
freeing and i think it shaped the whole
pancake lady idea in a way that i could
never imagine you always think about the
bad things that you go through at the
moment and it feels like it sucks and it
feels like it's the worst but as soon as
you find yourself a year later or two
years later and you see yourself on the
other side and it shows this is what
made me me it's crazy i look back and i
say if i wasn't picked on by all those
kids and if i didn't go through the
challenges of growing up and identifying
as a lesbian i wouldn't be the pancake
lady and i always tell people to just
embrace crazy things like that just
embrace what comes to you and be who you
are because at the end of the day i'm
not here to please anybody i make
pancakes for a living okay i had to tell
my mom i'm quitting my day job to make
pancakes for a living and i think it
kind of ties into just you got to do
what makes you happy and pancakes makes
me happy
all right i guess i'm going to try to
make my face this is the first time i
will be making my face as a pancake
seeing their face when they see
their face made as a pancake is the most
priceless reaction that you could ever
see it's honestly why i make pancake art
making sure i'm ready for liftoff giving
myself a little facelift before the flip
okay it's ready one two three
that's totally music pancake just by the
faces that everybody gives us once they
see the flip it's almost like a crowd
full of energy at their favorite concert
except they're in line to eat pancakes
[Music]
i love making pancake art because it's
given me the ability to connect with
strangers on a day-to-day basis
hear their story and hopefully impact
them with my own personal story
i strive to be the van gogh of pancake
art
[Music]
now that's a tasty pancake
oh yes
[Music]